[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute etwas
veganes ich hab das gestern durch zufall
gemacht weil ich hatte ich habe einfach
aus dem kühlschrank geöffnet habt
gewinnen okay
china habe ich noch da ich habe nur dlm
da ich habe cherry tomaten dann habe ich
ein leckeres nudelgericht gemacht und
dann kann's also nie probiert und der
war so hin und weg geld ausgegangen
er war so begeistert und dann gesagt
okay alles klar
dann finden wir das ab weil es ja echt
mega mega lecker und ich verspreche euch
dass ihr in maximal zehn minuten fertig
welt wenn nicht sogar unter 10 minuten
hpc spaghetti also wenn ihr das vegan
macht müssen durch darauf achten dass
ich spaghetti auch wegen sind so ist mir
jetzt jemand kochlöffel ich habe mich
nämlich immer mit spaghetti verschätzt
ich habe immer einen berg spaghetti
gekocht
denn da werden wir drei tage spaghetti
aber ab jetzt einmal so einmal hier
durch schieben und das ist dann eine
portion als sind dann in etwa 100 gramm
sondern davon dass jetzt zwei portionen
wir sind ja heute zu zweit und das koche
ich jetzt erstmal in salzwasser gar und
während es gar code zeige ich euch die
soße und dann ist schon alles fertig
[Musik]
ich schreibe euch natürlich alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben hier unten in die
video beschreibung und wir starten jetzt
mit der soße
dafür habe ich hier meine beschichtete
pfanne parat und ich benutze heute mein
olivenöl das ist so ein besonderes
produkt für mich ist es eher ein projekt
als ein produkt denn wir unterstützen
damit familien aus palästina und es ist
wichtig dass jetzt so sagen darf ich
glaube ich darf dass das leckerste
olivenöl dass mein gaumen je berührt hat
also ich unfassbar lecker ja also das
palästina kommt natürlich das steckt
natürlich ein bisschen herzblut auch
drin
ich werde jetzt ein bisschen was in
meine fahne gehen ihr dürft olivenöl
nicht stark erhitzen und deswegen
gunsten wir jetzt auch nur ich werde ihn
her jetzt einschalten maximal mittlere
stufe und da gebe ich jetzt zwiebeln
dazu die habe ich schon fein geschnitten
und knoblauch mein knoblauchpresse ich
immer für mich macht keinen unterschied
ob man schneidet reibt oder presst und
so günstig das ganze für ungefähr
anderthalb bis zwei minuten
[Musik]
so nachdem eineinhalb bis zwei minuten
schalte ich schon mal die herd fläche
aus also meine soße brauche jetzt nur
noch die reste zu
und da gebe ich jetzt keine rente ist
sesam buchs verlinke ich euch gibt es
auch bei mir im shop gebe ich jetzt
einmal mit dazu und zur tine kommt jetzt
ein spritzer zitronensaft
[Musik]
die sesam masse würzen wir dann noch mit
salz pfeffer wenn ihr mögt ein bisschen
chili und eine prise muskatnuss und
jetzt ist die masse dadurch das ist halt
die reste in der pfanne hatte ein
bisschen fester geworden und ich möchte
eine cremige konsistenz daher habe ich
mir jetzt eine kelle und krall mir was
vom nudelwasser und gäbe dass immer in
kleinen stücken mit dazu
[Musik]
so die fertig gegarten spaghetti kommen
jetzt mit zur sauce und ich mache es
oder sich ganz am ende noch klein
gehackte petersilie und halbierte
knackige cherrytomaten mit dazu geben
könnte die tomaten auch von anfang an
mit diensten das halt geschmackssache
ich habe es gestern aber von anfang an
gedünstet und heute habe ich gedacht die
sind so knackig ich gebe es da ganz am
ende mit dazu und ihr könnt das ganze
jetzt nachmachen probiert es unbedingt
aus das ist wirklich tausendundeine
nacht das ist mega orientalisch und ich
glaube ich mache das definitiv öfter und
leute verzeiht mir ich hab so ein
händler
das jetzt hier direkt von der fahne aus
könne also bis zum nächsten mal eure
kiki und wir haben sagen
[Musik]